let's see who else is holding how about
the 509 area code i'd love to hear
from our caller in 509 what's your name
where you calling from
[Music]
509 i can hear some background noise
there i don't know if you're aware i'm
talking to you
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
hello yes that's you
[Music]
me yes you
from 509 509 yeah
oh wow that caught me off guard yeah i
was just curious i just
listened to seniors package update from
the website hustle [ __ ]
and he said i'm sorry hold on a second i
don't unders i'm sorry
i don't understand a word you're saying
it sounds like you're coming to me from
underneath a towel what
you listen to what now it's a
um stimulus website um update
and the website's called hustle [ __ ]
and i was just curious because he said
that the feds are dumping a lot of the
stimulus money
into the stock market to raise the stock
markets up
right and that uh what's his name steven
i can't pronounce his last name
[Music]
this is a website called hustle [ __ ]
yeah and he just give me those updates
okay
and the and the argument is is that it's
bad that the government is pouring money
into the stock market or just that
that's what the government is
he said he's made that there's
allegations that the
feds are dumping a whole lot of the
stimulus money to raise the stock prices
up and everything else into junk bonds
and he also said that machuchin or
whatever his name is has dumped a lot of
stimulus money into some of his
wealthy counterparts machuchin is out of
control
he's he's a loose cannon you never know
what machuchin will do
but i guess they they've opened up their
coffers and stuff to keep the stock
market prices up and it's not going to
the stimulus packages that they need to
i guess they're they're dumping
trillions into it
the small allegations i've just heard i
just wondered if you've heard anything
about it too
yes so certainly there are multiple ways
in which stimulus money is used to prop
up stock market prices that the that's
absolutely happening now the junk bond
specific arguments that you're talking
about
i i'm less familiar with but i don't
know the website you're referring to i
don't know exactly what the allegations
that are being made are but early if you
go back to my tweets at the very start
of this entire stimulus
one of the things i was tweeting about
was how the stimulus is being used to
artificially prop up the stock market so
that
that passes the sniff test for me
yeah and then the other thing is with
pelosi doing what she's doing now
i'm i was kind of really angry at her
but after listening to that stuff i
don't know she's right and holding off
and not hold on a second you're talking
what specifically are you referring to
that nancy pelosi did
uh well between the arguments and stuff
between them and the republicans and
stuff about the stimulus packages and
stuff i was kind of getting angry at her
for not you know
getting something forward and everything
else and now i'm kind of going well
maybe she has a good idea on not doing
this because of what they're doing over
the republican side
right what state do you vote in i'm
curious
washington washington state spokane
washington all right very good
okay i really appreciate the call thank
you
yeah like i said if you could get more
information about that for me so i could
be more informed
i will i'm gonna look into that thank
you all right thanks for your time
all right take care uh okay